let's get this party started dear Santa
this is cake Pierce I've been really
good this year I just say bad words
every now and then but that's only what
my brother Teddy makes fun of me and I
lose my I've made my temper
let go you're gonna break it who cares
it's cameras like 20 years old I have to
work it's Christmas Eve you're gonna
stay home with your sister we should
make a video maybe we can get a shot of
Santa Claus you really have no clue do
you
nobody's do you realize how big of a
deal with it we need to get closer look
are you crazy
duck easiest position
five and in person one night only can
you go I don't go ho ho ho that's a myth
Christmas spirits down 35% half the
planets not gonna get toys so a few
brats don't get presents that's not the
end of the world people need Christmas
to remind themselves but how good they
can be Wendy you've got so big excuse me
you know what I mean grown up big now
Wendy we need a ride can you call an
uber you think I can pay the driver with
these imagine we all work together this
just might work you need to rally the
reindeer call me and bind the elves
please can you guys maybe we can still
save Christmas
so
less than an hour before the Sun rises
whoa let's get this party started
[Applause]
just like wait for Hanna and Jedi
mind-trick the cops I'm Santa Claus
Teddy not Yoda okay that's enough fun
for one day
[Music]
why must they keep drawing me like that
does my butt really look that big
you